- [Both] There can be only one
magical negro!
(dramatic music)
(both yelling)
♪ But I don't need ♪
(bell chiming)
(silly music)
(blowing raspberries)
(bell chiming)
(coins clinking)
(whimsical music)
(ding)
(bell chiming)
(slide whistling up)
- Wow.
(bell chiming)
(whimsical music)
(slide whistle)
(bell chiming)
(whimsical music)
(slide whistle)
(bell chiming)
(mischievous music)
(bell chiming repeatedly)
(suspenseful music)
(knocking)
- Was I speeding officer?
(loud chewing)
- You don't look like
you're from around here.
- No, sir.
(suspenseful music)
- You've been doing any drugs tonight?
- No, sir.
- Nope?
- No.
(loud chewing)
- Why don't you pop that trunk,
step out the vehicle for me please.
- Really?
- Yeah.
(rustling)
No drugs, huh?
- Nope.
- Well, well, well.
(trunk thudding)
What have we here?
- No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
You planted that in my car.
- Oh. Did I?
Or did I plant this?
- Uh, I guess the-
- Up against the car. Right
now. You just heard me.
Spread 'em!
- Uh.
- Huh? Whoa, whoa.
What do we have here? Huh?
- What?
- These your colors, homie?
- That's, that's not mine
- Huh?
- No, I.
No, I don't know what that-
- What, no?
Or are these your colors,
or perhaps these are your colors
or are these, look at
all these colors, man?
You sure got a lot of colors.
- I don't-
- Look at all of these colors.
- How was there-
- Wasah.
- Are you a real cop?
- Freeze! What is that?
Hm.
Well, well, well it looks
like an illegal firearm,
or
is it?
(dove cooing)
- Oh.
I'm, I don't, I don't know what this is.
I'm sorry.
- Pick a card.
- It's not even a good fan.
- Any card you can just stick it-
There, okay.
You took that card?
- Yeah.
- Now can you remember that card?
- Yes.
- Can you commit that card to memory?
- This is unbelievable.
- Have you done so? Have you done so?
- Yes.
- Please insert the card
back into the deck randomly.
- Done.
- It's in a different place
than where you took it originally?
- There.
- There we are.
There we are. Now.
- This is ridiculous.
- I take the deck like so,
I give it a scasloicles.
And, abracashroice.
(gun firing)
(civilian breathing heavily)
Okay.
Ah.
Is this your card?
- No.
- Are you sure?
- I want your badge number.
(civilian coughing)
- Oh, oh (cop gasping)
- What.
okay.
Oh.
How did.
How did you do that?
- And,
that is for you.
- After all that, you're
still giving me a ticket?
- Is it a ticket or is
it a two for one coupon
for my show at the magic house
Thursday night at 11:00 p.m..
Your call.
(teeth sucking)
- I'll take the ticket.
- Alright.
(wooshing)
- Oh no, please don't say anything.
Please just keep it to
yourself, whatever it is.
(Levi sneezing)
Oh, I thought you had an idea.
- I do.
(beep)
We need to make an app.
- Like for a smartphone?
- An app that all the
people could download
and then we make millions.
- They're just (beep) hard
to come up with man it's
like catching lightning in a bottle.
- I already got that.
- You got what?
- Lightning in a bottle.
- Really? What's the idea?
- No, no idea.
I got actual lightning in a bottle.
- No, Levi.
That's just a phrase.
- I got that dog.
(electricity buzzing)
Lightning in a bottle, blood.
- That's crazy son.
Where'd you get that?
- Some old Chinese man
sold it to me years ago.
- I mean, that's some
super natural (beep) man.
- Nah, man, all it does is this.
(Rumbling)
- Oh (beep) oh lightning, Oh.
- I got it.
But seriously, man.
Would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite
television shows are on?
- No.
We got to address this crazy
ass bottle that you got.
- What bottle?
- (beep) What bottle?
The bottle, with the lightning in it.
- You still on that?
- Yes. How does it work?
- Cedric, I don't know.
It's the classic
lightning in a bottle gag.
- Classic light-
- You just open it up
(rumbling)
(Cedric screaming)
- Okay, you know what?
You shouldn't have this,
this (beep) belongs to
the military or something.
- But that app though.
- No, we don't need the app.
You've got the goose
that laid the golden egg.
- How do you know about Honkers?
(mystical music)
- What? This motherf-
(goose squawks)
- Honkers, get in on this app idea.
You like it?
(goose squawks)
He likes it.
- Yeah. He got a god damn golden egg.
Honkers here is the cat's pajamas.
(suspenseful music)
No, please don't. Don't.
- I wanna show you something.
- Whatever it is, I don't wanna see it.
- It's relevant.
- I already know what it is.
- It ain't what you think.
- Well, what I think it is,
is a pair of, cat's pajamas.
- These are for Honkers to wear.
- (beep) what?
- The little neck in there.
- The neck-
How are you going to fit
his head through this thi-
With the, the orange hump (beep)?
(goose squawks)
- I'ma have to ask you to leave my house.
- Why?
- Because you disrespected my roommate.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Okay. It's clear that
this is a crazy house.
So I gotta go, you over
here talking about geese,
and golden eggs, and feline sleepwear.
(goose squawks)
- Aw man, Cedric!
You need to get off your high horse, man.
Hey I just thought of a name for you.
(mystical music)
High Horse.
(horse neighs)
(Levi laughs)
- But babe, moving out?
Please, this is the worst possible time.
Please don't do this.
Babe?
(sad music)
(wheels squeaking)
- [Janitor] Garbage.
- Huh?
- Can I take your garbage?
- Yeah, sure.
- (Janitor chuckles) You know,
I find, the more garbage in the can,
the better it feels to dump it all out.
I suppose that's why we let it get so full
in the first place.
So we can start over.
(snap)
(magical chiming)
- Here to fix the copier.
- Yeah, sure, sure.
Hey, how did you-
- [Repairman] Sometimes
things ain't really broken.
It's the way we treat 'em,
that needs to be fixed.
(magical chiming)
(copy machine whirring)
(mystical music)
(repairman whistling)
(bird whistling)
(repairman laughing)
(ding)
- Who the hell are you guys?
- [Both] The important question is.
Who are you
- Steve?
(ominous music)
Well, if it isn't Mr. Stanley.
- Carl.
(ominous music)
- You need to find your
own troubled white boy.
(ominous music)
- I was here first.
Copycat!
(explosion)
(repairman coughing)
(repairman growling)
- Sweep this.
(laser whizzing)
(janitor thudding)
(janitor breathing heavily)
(repairman laughing evily)
(suspenseful music)
(janitor snapping)
- Oh.
(explosion)
(repairman thudding)
(repairman breathing heavily)
(janitor laughing evily)
(electricity buzzing)
(dramatic music)
(paper whipping)
(stars whirring)
(magic thwiping)
(projectiles whizzing)
- Damn!
Chesterfield.
(repairman whistling)
(bird cawing)
(dramatic music)
- [Both] There can be only one.
Magical Negro!
(both grunting)
(dramatic music)
(electricity crackling)
(magic zipping)
(high pitch whistle)
(both yelling)
(explosion)
(car alarms ringing)
(glass shattering)
(papers rustling)
(electric wire crackling)
- Good lord,
are you alright?
Well.
I guess sometimes things
have to come apart
before we can put 'em back together again.
- Oh, you're a magical Negro too.
- Who you callin' Negro bitch.
(acapella beat)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need ♪